this is most likely true
and the most likely to swear would be
Eddie in the movie and me in real life
the most likely to bust out the craziest
dance moves would be Jonah Hill Jonah
would be dancing some funny dances the
one who is most likely to mention in the
most mind-blowing story from the past it
would be a tie between Nia Long and
Eddie Murphy the most likely to be
cleaning their house while having a
party is me because I have I'm a little
neurotic about things and places and
places and things the most disruptive
laugh Kenya Barris can you laugh behind
the camera a lot great laugh but that's
how we would know that the take was
great thank you for having me Drew and I
will see you next time